welcome to the science Asylum I Nick
lucid Soler's watching Star Wars
recently and I noticed Han Solo said
this it's the ship that made the Kessel
run in less than 12 parsecs actually a
parsecs immune of distance to that claim
with no physical sense hmm you know what
we're gonna try to make some sense of it
anyway for those of you who don't know
the Kessel run is an 18 parsecs strip of
space in the Star Wars galaxy that
smugglers use to transport spice it's
kind of tough to get through because
it's monitored by Imperial forces not
that Imperial forces are known for being
good shots or even all that smart anyway
let's start with a little bit of reality
about writing stories in the revised 4th
draft of the script of Star Wars a new
hope immediately following that line
from Han it says Ben reacts to solo
stupid attempt to impress them with
obvious misinformation which seems to
suggest that Han was purposefully giving
them a load of crap however in the
official audio commentary George Lucas
claims odd news units of parsecs because
the Millennium Falcon's navigation
system is so sophisticated they can
calculate a straighter path through
hyperspace which seems that suggests
that Han was telling the truth
backpedal backpedal backpedal t-totally
inconsistent yes it's inconsistent but
we like to think of books in movies as
though they contain completely
self-consistent worlds that actually
exist so what would it take to actually
shorten 18 parsecs to 12 first if we're
going to use a unit like parsec we
better know what it means it's actually
short for parallax of an arc second to
make some sense of it we're gonna have
to zoom out no no like way out just keep
going until I tell you to stop keep
going keep going
okay stop out here you can see the
entire orbit of Earth if we look at this
nearby star it looks like it's by these
distant stars
six months later though it looks like
it's over here it's kind of like when
you're driving down the road and the
faraway things look like they're moving
a lot slower than the closer things that
difference is called parallax and it's
the same thing your two eyes used to
give you depth perception number one
number two camera one camera two an arc
second is an angle measurement one
thirty six hundredth of a degree to be
specific
just like how a second is one thirty six
hundredths of an hour so like a super
small angle divisions like this are left
over from ancient Babylon where they had
if the Earth's parallax of a nearby star
forms an angle of one arcsecond
then the star is said to be one parsec
away from Earth
which is about three and a quarter
light-years or 19 trillion miles
you can review that unit anyway because
Earth doesn't exist in this thyroid
galaxy maybe not but humans evolved on
earth partly because the Sun is just the
right size and the earth is just the
right distance away any fictional planet
that involves humans will have it
comparable sized orbit boom so the
question remains how do we turn eighteen
parsecs into twelve the ships and star
wars jump into something called
hyperspace actually hyperspace is
completely effective no Oh doesn't
matter if it's fiction we'll just go
with me here we can assume the fictional
physics of hyperspace doesn't shorten
distances because if that were true han
wouldn't be boasting about distance it
doesn't make any sense we can also
assume that hyperspace isn't just slang
for almost Lightspeed because it nearly
light speed even 12 parsecs would take
40 years to travel the delivery dates
would be totally impractical we also
know that everything with mass travels
slower than the speed of light which
leaves us with only one option for
hyperspace
it's a portion of space where the speed
of light is faster than usual
so inside hyperspace you can travel much
faster than usual and the navigation
computer just has a map of where it all
is in which parts are safe and since the
speed of light is faster you're still
not moving at a significant fraction of
it so special relativity doesn't apply
but general relativity still can as
we've seen before gravity affects
objects by changing what straight lines
look like changing the shape of space
also changes its size when a small star
like the Sun isn't gonna cut it
we're gonna need a bigger mass hardcore
Star Wars fans have suggested that Han
might have used a set of black holes
called the Mach cluster actually that's
not that we're scanning that suspended
universe which makes our legends didn't
you get that memo fine 18 parsecs is a
pretty big region of space we can assume
somewhere in there there's at least one
black hole completely empty space is
described by this equation this space
around a black hole is described by this
equation the identical stuff shows how
space is unaffected by the black hole so
we'll ignore those
so only interested in space not time so
we'll ignore this too and we can see now
the black hole only affects space along
radial lines if we take a ruler and wait
a second the distances are bigger when
you get closer to the black hole getting
close to a black hole makes the Kessel
run longer not shorter so have you ever
thought this deeply about a fictional
world if so which woman let us know in
the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy